.
Let's solve a few verbal tasks by using
exponential growth and decrease.
In the first task we have radioactive material decomposition
at a rate of 3.5% per hour.
How many percent of the substance will remain after 6 hours?
Let me make a small table here,
to imagine what's going on.
And then we will try to draw a general formula
how much is left after n hours.
Let's say outgoing hours
and remaining percentages,
How many percent left after 0 hours?
Well, it has not yet collapsed so we have 100% left.
What happened after 1 hour?
The substance breaks down at a rate of 3.5% per hour.
So 3.5% have gone.
In other words this is 0.965.
Do not forget that if you take 1 minus 3.5%
or if you take 100% minus 3.5% - it shows how much we lose every hour -
and equals 96.5%.
So every hour we will have 96.5%
of the quantity in the previous hour.
At hour 1 we have 96.5% of hour 0
or 0.965 per 100, by the amount at hour 0.
What's going on in class 2?
Time 2.
We have 96.5% of the amount in the previous hour.
We will have lost 3.5%
which means we have 96.5% of the previous hour.
It will be 0.965 on that,
multiplied by 0.965 by 100.
I think you see what's happening in general.
In the first hour we have 0.965 at grade 1,
multiplied by 100.
At the zero hour we have 0.965 at zero.
We do not see it, but there is a unit multiplied by 100.
In the second hour, we have 0.965 at degree 2 multiplied by 100.
And in general at n-th hour - let me write it in
nice bright color - we'll have the n-th hour
0.965 at n grade, multiplied by 100,
which is left of our radioactive substance.
You will often find it written in this way.
You have the initial value
multiplied by private 0.965 to n degree.
That's how it will stay after n hours.
Now we can answer the question:
How old is it after 6 hours?
We will have the remaining 100 multiplied by 0.965 at sixth.
We can use a calculator to calculate how much it is.
Let's use our faithful calculator.
We have 100 at 0.965 at sixth grade, which is
equal to 80.75.
That's all in percent.
So 80.75% of our original substance remains.
80.75%.
Let's make another example like this.
Given that Nadia has a fast food chain,
which in 1999 had 200 sites.
If the rate of increase is ...
Oh, there's a typo.
Here should be 8% -
the growth rate is 8% per year
how many stores will the chain have in 2007?
Let's apply the same logic.
Here we have years after 1999.
And here we have how many restaurants there will be Nadia, or hers
fast food chain.
1999 itself is 0 years after 1999.
and it has 200 stores.
Then in 2000, which was 1 year after 1999,
how many restaurants will there be?
Well it grows at a rate of 8% per year.
So there will be all the restaurants she had before,
plus 8% of the restaurants she had previously.
1.08 multiplied by the number of restaurants it had previously.
And as you will see, private here is 1.08.
If it grows by 8%, it is equivalent to
a multiplication of 1.08.
Let's make it clear.
200 plus 0.08 multiplied by 200.
Well, it's only 1 in 200 plus 0.08 multiplied by 200.
That's 1.08 by 200.
Then what happened in 2001?
These are already 2 years since 1999, and there is an increase
with 8% of this figure.
You will multiply 1.08 by this number,
multiplied by 1.08 multiplied by 200.
I think I understood the essence.
n years after 1999 this will be 1.08 -
let me write it this way:
will be 200 at 1.08 at n grade.
After 2 years it is 1.08 per square.
After one year is 1.08 in the first degree.
0 years, it's the same as 1 in 200, which
is 1.08 at zero.
The condition asks how many restaurants work
will there be in 2007?
2007 is 8 years after 1999.
So here n equals 8.
Let us replace n with 8.
The answer to our question is 200 at 1.08 at eight.
Let's get our calculator and calculate it.
We want to calculate 200 by 1.08
to eighth degree.
It will have 370 restaurants and it will be
in the process of opening a few more.
So if we round it down,
it will have 370 restaurants.
8% growth may not seem like something that's so fast
or so exciting.
But in less than a decade, in only eight years, it would increase
its chain of restaurants from 200 to 370 restaurants.
You see that for an 8-year increase of 8%
it is actually very impressive.
.